this is Caesar Augustus he was the first
official emperor of the Roman Empire and
if you've ever had to study Roman
history you might be familiar with this
little sculpture is very famous original
it's called the Augustus of primaporta
it was carved in the 1st century AD
during his reign as Emperor then it was
lost a time before it was dug up again
in 1860s today it lives in the Vatican
Museums alongside a bunch of other
famous sculptures but Augustus he's not
supposed to look like this he's supposed
to look like this
[Music]
let's get this out of the way ancient
Greece and Rome were really colorful
their buildings were full of intricate
frescoes and elaborate mosaics and
covered with violently painted statues
of things like epic battles glimmering
gods and pretty flowers but today most
of us picture something more like this
brilliant white marble as far as the eye
can see
we're wrong but it's not our fault it's
Hollywood's fault and our high school
textbooks fall but most of all it's this
guy's fault well not him he's just a
statue
the blame lies with Michelangelo the guy
who sculpted him and with many others
who made white marble statues during the
Renaissance when European artists
philosophers and scientists developed a
renewed interest in the creations of
classical Greece and Rome artists like
Michelangelo began studying Roman
sculptures like this one
Lao kun and his sons they fell in love
with its lifelike figures dramatic scene
and pristine white surface but
sculptures like this weren't meant to be
white their paint had just faded after
being buried or left out in the open air
for hundreds of years so when the
Renaissance artist set out to imitate
them they left their masterpieces bare -
and that style took over inspiring
generations of sculptors white marble
became the norm along the way our
historians reinforce this bias namely
this guy Johann Joaquin vinkle Minh he
sometimes known as the father of art
history in the 18th century
he wrote a hugely influential book on
ancient art in it he argued that statues
like this one the Apollo of Belvedere
were the epitome of beauty because the
wider the body is the more beautiful it
is he went out of his way to ignore
obvious evidence of coloured marble and
there was a lot of it especially after
the rediscovery of the ancient Roman
city of Pompeii in the 1700s Pompey's
near perfectly preserved frescoes
featured all sorts of colored statues
and one particular mural of an artist in
the act of painting a sculpture
this colorful sculpture was also found
in Pompeii Benkelman claimed it was too
primitive to have been made by them but
evidence wasn't just ignored some of it
might have been destroyed
remember Augustus when archeologists
rediscovered him in the 1860s they sized
his tunic was crimson his armor was
yellow and his mantle that's this thing
was purple and this is him now it's
unclear if Augustus lost his color by
accident as a result of over cleaning or
if it was removed on purpose but either
way the same thing happened to a bunch
of other famous monuments and sculptures
like the Parthenon in Athens which once
looks something like this by the 18th
century it had faded to something more
like this with just hints of color left
but today even those are gone luckily
our historians have since shifted to
believe it's not about what people think
looks better it's about what's accurate
but how do they get from this to this to
start there are some surviving ancient
descriptions of more famous sculptures
which is how we know that the Parthenon
once held a statue of the goddess Athena
that was ivory and gold wearing a helmet
adorned with the likeness of his Fink's
and if you look closely at some
sculptures there's still obvious traces
of color like the remnants of deep
purple on this Statutes clothing that's
how early reconstructions like these are
made today scientists can extract and
test those tiny samples to determine the
original pigments used but when there
aren't any visible colors they have
another tool ultraviolet light certain
pigments glow under UV light exposing
traces that would have been otherwise
invisible when scientists photograph
this archers legs under UV light they
saw this a dizzying array of geometric
patterns and saturated colors and when
they compared it to trace pigments on a
similar statue they were able to make
this reconstruction which to be clear is
about as ancient as mine because
conservationists never add color to the
original they use 3d scanners to create
plaster replicas which they then
painstakingly repaint with far greater
accuracy than I can
[Music]
seeing these sculptures in full-color
might be a little shocking at first but
that's probably because we've only seen
them one way for centuries to the Greeks
and the Romans painting a sculpture made
it complete color can make marble seem
human or godlike it infused them with
drama and emotion it brought history and
mythology to life and even though these
reconstructions aren't perfect
seeing these statues in color can bring
us a little closer to understanding what
the ancient world might have looked like
[Music]